I do have a personal philosophy I'm an
atheist I believe that if you have a
religion it should be sort of to your
personal principles in my case I believe
kindness is one of the best religions
that you can have and in fact all the
major religions are founded on that
principle
it's just that followers deviate from it
over a period of time Muhammad used to
say to his followers never to overload a
donkey to rest the donkey never to throw
stones at a bird all these things in
Judaism there are many rabbis who say
that you shouldn't eat animals that you
shouldn't wear ever wear the fur of
animals in Christianity of course no
Jesus knew of a little sparrow fell and
was always advocating kindness to all
living beings and Buddhism Hinduism the
gamut so to me the core value is
kindness and just
you